there might be trouble ahead for Disney
and could that trouble actually lead
them to having to sell one of their
biggest franchises
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
I heard this rumor
a couple of months ago now and I laughed
it off I told the person that told me
that they were being ridiculous stupid
even and that this was never going to
happen the Disney was simply too big to
sell such a massive franchise but the
room has persisted and now I've heard it
from a couple of different sources but
why is Disney considering selling
lucasfilm it's just been announced that
they are starting their first round of
massive layoffs 4 000 people are going
to be laid off between now and Thursday
and in the summer a further 3 000
layoffs are planned that is the biggest
layoff in Disney's history seven
thousand people the staff at Disney are
calling it The bloodbath now even though
this isn't going to affect the Frontline
staff at the like theme parks and things
this is going to affect Disney across
the board ESPN the theme parks Etc at
the entertainment side there is going to
be layoffs across the board they are
trying to make five billion dollars
worth of savings because basically
they're hemorrhaging money now obviously
kovid wasn't the best time for Disney
they did you know have basically have to
shut their Parks the Cornerstone of
their business and really the most
profitable part of their business for
like what 18 months that obviously had
an effect
they also started Disney plus and in an
attempt to catch up with Netflix decided
to invest massive amounts of money
now I've actually told you before that
they were losing 500 million dollars a
quarter well that's old news they lost a
billion dollars in the last quarter and
1.5 billion in the quarter before that
on their streaming services so
keep it up on Netflix is quite expensive
apparently and even though Disney plus
has had massive increases in subscriber
numbers in the last quarter it had its
first decrease losing 2.4 million now
all of the subscription services are
suffering from this book for Disney
that's such a young
but for Disney that is spending
and for Disney he was spending so much
money to catch up to the other
subscription Services coming to this so
late in the game they really can't
afford backward steps like that
now all of the scripts and services are
having the same problem there's a cost
of living crisis people are panicking
about the dollar and the pound and
they're thinking I don't need four or
five streaming services two will do and
Disney Netflix Amazon etc etc are all
feeling the squeeze there's only really
Apple that aren't feeling the squeeze
but that's because Apple TV plus is
really fed by the rest of the business
remembering that apple is the most
valuable business on the planet so
Disney is losing money they need to save
a crapload of money could this problem
actually lead to the unthinkable them
selling lucasfilm well talking to an
Insider that I speak to that does
actually work in this part of me is
actually works in the legal side of
things but this is his area he's telling
me that this rumor has been going around
for a while now apparently they did look
at Marvel initially thinking could we
sell Marvel Studios and to be honest
that was decided as a no because Marvel
Studios is worth more to them they have
more content being produced from Marvel
they also have all of the comic books
etc etc Marvel is generally more
adaptable franchise and they think they
can squeeze more out of it at the moment
lucasfilm only really has Indiana Jones
and Star Wars so it's a little bit more
limited now according to my guy when
this sale if it were to happen Disney
would build in a bunch of Clauses which
would basically mean whoever did buy it
would still have to produce material for
Disney so from a customer's perspective
we might not actually see any difference
Star Wars Etc would still be on Disney
plus Disney would be able to get a nice
cash injection at a time when they
really need it and they would actually
get a lot of cost off their books
somebody else would have to then produce
the material and Disney would just
become a customer buying TV shows from
them so if you think about it this deal
might makes sense it lowers their risk
it lowers their outgoings but actually
doesn't affect the end product
however it also does lower their
long-term profits Star Wars is you still
have to remember pretty much a cash cow
but it's not the cash cow it once was
merchandise is still pretty good for
them but again not like what it was in
the 90s the early 90s and before Star
Wars made massive profits for
merchandising but people just don't buy
toys and things like that as much as
they used to
kids watch YouTube and play Xbox they
don't really play with model attacks and
things so they're not getting as much
money out of it as they once did
lucasfilms doesn't actually produce a
wide range of content
and it's a really easy sell because
somebody might be willing to buy it I'm
actually genuinely wondering if George
Lucas might be interested in taking the
business back
it wouldn't shock me but there'd be
investment firms queuing around the
block to get their hands on a franchise
like that so a rumor that I dismissed is
stupid and laughable
might not actually be as stupid and
laughable as I thought
Star Wars genuinely could be up for sale
and I'd love to know exactly what you
think about that so please get into the
comments does this rumor as ridiculous
as it sounds on the surface actually
maybe makes sense and I don't know crazy
things have happened
or is Disney just too big to fail and
would it just be too embarrassing for
Mickey Mouse and friends to let this
happen
get to the concert tell me exactly what
you think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you get to see
most of our new videos first without the
adverts for a small contribution that
really helps the channel out each month
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]